[Music]
we're going to go out to this is Sparta
Tennessee uh let's open up to Jesse what
up Jesse what's going on Dr John we're
just making it happen dude all right and
so I'm gonna bring your uh wife on is
that right yeah all right hang on one
second I'm gonna bring on
Haley all right Haley Haley why you bug
are you on yes I Dr John all right so I
got Jesse and Haley here from Sparta
Tennessee all right so uh who wants to
go
first uh I'll go first okay who's in the
most trouble here how about that uh that
would be me I'm the one that's always
causing the trouble all right let's
start with you go for it all right well
we've been in kind of a tough spot for
quite a while now and every time we have
difficult conversations about something
that I've done um I always tend to
distance myself from whatever the
situation may be or try to minimize my
involvement my question is how do I
fully open up my wife and not be
dishonest with her during those
difficult conversations tell the
truth am I am I over am I
oversimplifying it no no you're not
it's I've always I've always done that
like tried to distance myself from I
guess what I've done like tried to
minimize my involvement and I I don't
know I don't know how to stop
it I mean normally half the battle
that's not true two-thirds of the battle
is helping somebody recognize that
they've got something they need to do
differently new actions they need to
take you know that yeah
so give me an example of something or
there something must have happened for
y'all to call what happened recently
that you're that you're trying to
minimize your distance yourself from and
you don't want to do that anymore well
um like at work I started a new job here
recently and uh there was this coworker
of mine it was a female and we started
talking and it wasn't nothing out of the
ordinary just two co-workers talking but
then we started flirting and and that's
as far as it went and
as far as I I would allow it to go and I
told her you know twice that I was
married but I tried to my wife asked me
several times about it and I kept
telling her that nothing was going on
and I wasn't doing anything I hadn't
done anything wrong but I knew that it
was wrong just to
even be communicating with her flirting
with her so let's let's let's hone in on
the word
flirt um there's been people in my life
when I've been married over 21 years
that i' would say that's just kind of I
especially in the old days like that was
kind of my
energy but there was no text messages
there so people use the word flirt and
it's just
like being
extra um connected if you will then some
people say no we were just flirting and
you were
sending um nude piics back and forth to
each other so be very specific Describe
the word flirt to me uh just you know
laughing and carrying on we never we
never sent lty text or anything back and
forth never phone calls nothing like
that it was just you know we were
talking and with laughs at each other's
jokes or whatever and just I don't know
so I don't understand what the problem
is like I laugh at Kelly's jokes all the
time I flirting but I laugh at her jokes
all the time she does not laugh at my
jokes because most of my jokes are
directed at her
right but but I don't understand the
what's the
problem she says that I had an emotional
affair on her even though I never I
never said anything about her or to to
her about my wife or anything that was
going on between us or nothing like that
and it never went any further than just
conversations Haley what am I missing
here
well for one thing uh he started acting
really different to
me and like not wanting to have much to
do with me and he looked me dead in my
eyes and told me he was going to go
sleep with that girl three different
times hold on hold on hold on hold on
haly hold on Jesse you kind of left that
part
out did you look your wife in the eye
and say you're gonna go sleep with
somebody else never directly no yes he
did
I I mean I in so many words yes I did I
told her if she didn't shut up then I
was going to do that which I probably
shouldn't have I'd say that's a lot of
this problem
here why did you tell your wife to shut
up or you going to go hook up with a
coworker because at that time nothing
was going on and she just kept on and
kept on and we do not have grownup adult
conversations it's always screaming and
yelling and accusing and most of the
time it's just
accusing so is before I go back to Haley
Jesse is there here's the deal this is
as honest as I can
be there are couples like you and Haley
yeah
where there is a woman in this
relationship always always always
picking threatening pointing out what
about this I can't believe you did that
and the guy in the in the relationship
is always like feels like they're tap
dancing in velvet shoes on on thin
ice yeah and there's also idiotic
husbands
who cheat on their wives and then 5
years later get mad that they still and
still flirt with co-workers and talk
about co-workers
and are looking at pornography when
they're supposed to be in the other room
having dinner and I could just the the
the don't call and they're late five
hours I could just make an entire list
here and so you leave a wife struggling
and grasping for straws and creating
stories to backfill
horrific bad husband Behavior I say bad
husband that sounds like a child but
very childish husband Behavior
well say I'm I'm always home as soon as
I get off work I tell her I'm headed
home I come straight home from work and
I'm I'm with her every time I'm not at
work I'm with her okay Haley what am I
missing here I mean it's starting to
feel more more like a like Jerry
Springer like what like tell me what am
I missing is he's been lying to me and
he downplay things for like seven years
there's been a lot of Deceit there's
been a lot of stuff he's done give me
some examples give me some examples him
what about what give me some
examples um well he had sh on me like
years ago eight years ago I think um and
then um we are both recovered addicts
okay but um there was one time he was
using behind my back for seven months
okay and was lying to me and it it just
got drug out and I every every time he
does something he never gives me
time to heal from that before he does
something
else
and how do Haley how do you Haley how do
you heal from
things it's just really T I guess and I
try to trust him but he's always
deceiving me and manipulating me and
tells me I'm crazy like the thing at
work he went up there told all his
co-workers that I was just making that
stuff up that he didn't do
anything and I I believe him I just
really believe there's more to it than
what he's letting
on because he's my husband and I know
him okay and he's just so
distant and I just feel like he's more
invested in that girl then he will let
on because I asked him two two months
ago to get transferred he refused
um it's just everything I asked him to
do to help me in this marriage is like
he'll do it for a couple of days and
then it's just me like holding
everything together by
myself so here's here's the truth of the
of the situation Haley as quickly as I
can get to
it either your um radar
system is wildly over over poignant it's
wildly over sensitive to
stimuli MH and every single thing this
poor man does your body reacts as though
you know the truth he's doing this he's
lying about this he's using this he's
cheating on me over here that could be
either
that or
Jesse you called my show and you can lie
in your house dude but you can't call
this show and disrespect me and all the
people who Tune In by not telling the
truth oh I know that and you're slowly
drowning your water and I drowning your
wife and gaslighting your wife to
death so I'll ask you just point blank
if we're going to do this let's do it
are you honest and nothing happened
between you and this woman at work zero
things I swear to you zero things
happened okay zero what is it about your
interactions with
her and your relationship with your wife
that is setting every setting your
wife's
emotional senses on
fire I guess it's because we've been so
distant from each other for the past
don't know so
long and then every time something
happens it's like she's either accusing
me of something or I'm lying about this
or I'm lying about that and a lot of the
times it's it has nothing to do with
anything why do you lie to her then is
it e let me ask you this is it easier to
lie to her on little things because you
don't want to get poked and prodded and
pulled apart and threatened and all that
well see the thing is is that most of
the time I tell her the truth most of
the time it's just the these big things
I try to minimize my involvement in but
I guess I tell her it's no I don't want
to hurt her feelings but I know that's
not
it I guess it's just cuz I don't want to
let her down or I want her to be right
about me I
guess because she always accuses me of
like doing stuff on my phone and it and
none of it's been true and we'll sit
down and go through everything and she
still believes what she thinks even
after we talk about everything Haley is
that
right there will be like history on his
phone like all these texting apps and
video apps and chatting apps and stop
and all that started when he started
talking to that girl but he still denies
it but there's history on his phone he
lied to me about even being around that
girl for the longest this has been going
on for months and two weeks ago is when
he admitted that he had other intentions
with her after looking me in my eyes and
saying all that
stuff
and I just I don't know I just feel like
there's more to it he says there's not
but he'll drag it out for years before
he'll tell me the truth about one little
thing he does have a problem with porn
always
has and he lies about that for years and
then he'll finally be like oh yeah this
time but haly why do you stay married to
him you can't sleep you don't trust him
as far as you can I mean you can't you
don't trust him the moment he walks into
the next bedroom much less out the front
door and listen No Matter listen no
matter what he
says you think he's lying to you you
think he's cheating on you you think he
might be using again you think he's
deceiving deceiving
you he's cheated on you before why are
you in this
marriage I love him and we have a family
together we've been together for 13
years and I just I know he's a better
person but he just
refuses to to give me what I need and
I've gave seven years
and I don't know he keeps giving me
false promises but all his actions say
different than his
words so Jesse I'm just going to ask you
one more time and then I'll I'll wrap
this call up and give you all a little
what little Direction I can possibly
give
you okay you called me and said you
minimize things that's a sophisticated
way of seeing you lie about things to
make yourself less of a culprit in a
situation
yeah this whole call you said you don't
lie you always tell the truth you always
come home nothing ever happens no no I
lied to her I do lie to her but whenever
it's I lie to her only about like
certain things things that I actually
have done I lied to her about name them
give me a
couple well like um the porn thing I
lied to her about that okay what else
what else talking talking to that girl I
lied to her about that what
else um how long have you got keep going
rattle them
off
um I that's just to the biggest things
that I can I really keep going now
you're doing what you called me and
asked me about you distancing yourself
from it go say
it I'm looking at other women I lied to
her about that for years okay keep going
that's seriously all I can think of it's
not there's more keep going I'm sure
there is more I just why do you have a
whole bunch of video chatting um apps on
your phone I don't I do not
and no it says whenever you go on my
history it says um something download
whatever that video app is called but I
have never used it never I've never used
a texting app I've never used a video
chatting app I've never used any of that
stuff and she can go through all the
apps that have ever been on my phone
because they're still there you just
happen to to download them and you just
like held on to them they've never been
downloaded that's what I'm saying
they've never been downloaded all right
well here here here's the deal here's
the
deal Haley this is just dude I've talked
to y'all for for I don't know 10 minutes
Haley I think that there's been a World
created
both by both of
y'all where you are unable to walk with
any sort of certainty on the foundation
that is in your that is your home that
is your marriage that is your
relationship
period Jesse if you are
completely 100% innocent here which
there's not one cell in my body that
believes that but if you
are lying for years about you
about a an affair about pornography
about talking to other women about
looking other women telling your wife to
shut up or you're going to go sleep with
the lady at
work etc etc
etc you've created a context in your
home you've created you've pumped air
into your home that makes it impossible
for your wife to
breathe and Haley if he's not doing all
these things and you are just have a
pair of glasses on that is constantly
looking for a reason why you've got to
get worked up about something you're
going to find it you're going to imagine
it whether it's on his phone or not
here's what I have to
say this will be the rest of your life
unless yall decide to do something
different together Jesse your life will
be misery and it will be hell until you
100% tell the truth and I'm telling you
I don't think you're telling the truth
that's just me Haley you will never have
peace in your home and your marriage
until a Jesse tells the truth B you
decide to forgive and C you all decide
to build something new together end of
story
period but if you choose to stay in a
marriage in 100% of your day is looking
for places where he may or may not or
I'm just confident I know it where he's
doing things to hurt you and hurt your
marriage what do you why why would you
do that why would you live live that
life and Jesse why would you stay
married if you're with somebody who
thinks so little of you and thinks you
are lying to them all the time 24/7 365
all the time and you're just this
innocent guy trying to make a living
trying to do good work yeah you flirt at
work but you don't do anything wrong
ever why would you stay in this
marriage there will will be no peace in
your home Jesse and Haley until youall
both decide to tell the
truth there will be no peace in your
home Jesse and Haley until yall
decide once all the truth is on the
table I'm going delete everything from
my phone
period if it means that much to you I
will not go back I will get transferred
to the next town over and I will not go
to that place but when I do this you
can't keep you cannot keep hassling me
about things that are not happening
happening I will never minimize
something that I do wrong and I'll never
yell and call you stupid and tell you to
shut up woman and I'm sleeping with
other women I'm never going to talk to
you like that because nobody deserves to
be talked like that and I'm not going to
scrutinize every little tiny Breath You
Take to see if you're doing this and
cheating this and line I'm gonna
stop because peace is worth more than
that I can't recommend this enough if
y'all got to stop what you're doing just
stop both of you and decide to go see
somebody a counselor in your local
commun there in Sparta please do that
please do
that that's as far as I can go on this
call
guys there's some honesty that needs to
happen in your home there's some
forgiveness that needs to happen in your
home and there's a radical control alt
delete that needs to happen with how you
talk to each other and how you plan for
what happens
tomorrow